the volkswagen tiguan has been around
the block a few times now the compact
suvs been around since 2007 it's name a
combination of the german words for
tiger and iguana was chosen back then by
the readers of a car magazine
the tiguan has always cut a dynamic
figure but it's changed over time since
2011 it has featured angled headlights
it's practical too plastic cladding
protects the body work for mud for
driving over muddy terrain back to that
name what does it really mean yeah
tiguan is that are testifying hold
explains it's a cross between a tiger
and an iguana the tiger of course being
a deadly predator native to Asia and the
iguana the camouflage specialist of
North and South America and Germany
though the tiguan is the king of the
compact SUVs it's competing with the
toyota rav4 the Kia Sportage and the
Ford Kuga the most remarkable feature of
the tiguan is that it's inconspicuous
maybe that's why Germans love it the 125
kilowatt engine is also great for
off-road driving the two-liter turbo
diesel engine produces 320 newton meters
of torque through 1,750 revolutions per
minute the all-wheel drive system
delivers plenty of power split between
the two axles by a Haldex clutch
all of that means the car is secure is
can be out on the road but it also
consumes more gas than the front wheel
drive version and the model we're
testing has a top speed of about 190
km/h
oh boy daddy 10 vinyl says although the
tiguan can go off-road it's also great
on the street that's no surprise given
its similarities to two other VW models
the Posada and the Gulf and anyone who's
ever ridden in a Volkswagen before will
feel at home in this car stands out from
the competition with its adaptive
chassis which allows drivers to go for a
ride that focuses on speed or comfort
with the comfort setting giving
passengers are particularly smooth
experience bazan discuss my D up
adding to that experience are these
special seats which come as standard
there's plenty of space in the back to
practicality comes to the fore here as
well there is a fold-out table and the
seats can be put away to make more
storage room
whether on the streets or off-road the
tiguan is an all-rounder that suits all
conditions
if i'll be t go on a step i know'd can
see why the tingle one leads the market
for compact SUVs it doesn't have any
weaknesses and meets Volkswagens high
standards for quality and performance
but at 25 thousand euros it doesn't come
cheap the all-wheel drive for motion
model is more expensive at twenty-nine
thousand euros more varieties are due to
be released soon as well as a larger
seven seater in a coop a version to
compete with BMWs x-series the American
SUV market is especially important for
Volkswagen none of their models feature
in the top 20 most popular cars in that
class I'd second focus wagon okay no
here mr. Povey atomic pompton the new
additions will freshen the series up
bukaty go on already has everything it
needs to justify its place at the top of
the compact SUV market aside from its
drivability features it also boasts
great safety standards it was awarded
five stars by the car safety program
hero and cap
you